the job of Iraqi prime minister is a
balancing act between Invader turn
strategic partner the United States and
paramilitary groups close to Iran whose
support is crucial for holding power in
Bagdad but the balance appears to be
shifting after a US drone strike on
Thursday killed a senior leader from one
of the dozens of armed groups that make
up Iraq's popular mobilization forces
the second such attack in recent months
on the Iraqi
paramilitary prime minister Muhammad
shiel Sudani said the presence of the
us-led coal in Iraq needs to come to an
end the popular mobilization forces
represent an integral part of our Armed
Forces we have repeatedly emphasized
that in the event of a violation or
transgression by any Iraqi party or if
Iraqi law is violated the Iraqi
government is the only party that has
the right to follow up on the merits of
these
violations mus Jawad kazim Al jawari and
three other members of the group harj
were killed on Thursday by us missiles
what the Iraqi government says is
another violation of sovereignty the
Pentagon says was self-defense this was
a necessary and proportion and action
against this particular individual who
was personally involved in the planning
and execution of attacks against
American
Personnel 2500 US troops in Iraq another
900 in Syria lead a so-called
International Coalition to stop isil
from coming back but Iraqis will tell
you US forces do whatever they want
whenever they want off in violating
standing agreements we cannot expect
that the American troops will continue
to stay in Iraq forever and because of
what's happening in the region and
recently in bagdan and bombing different
places in Iraq with certain missiles and
killing people here of course this uh is
not accepted neither by the Iraqi public
neither by the government the Iraqi
government still relies on the us-led
Coalition for security they are unlikely
to be asked to leave anytime soon but in
the face of escalating violence saying
it out loud
was the least the Iraqi government could
do there have been more than a 100
attacks on us bases in Iraq and Syria
since the war on Gaza began by groups
sympathetic to the plight of the
Palestinian people it is the allout
American support for Israel critics say
that made those attacks inevitable Zan
basravi Al jazer Bagdad